[موسيقى]
على كل من الشارقه تنضم الينا الشريط
التغذيه العلاجيه دكتوره وفاء حلمي دكتوره
مساء الخير يسعد مساكي رمضان كريم كل عام
وانت بالف خير معانا هذه المره في رمضان
ومساء
مساء الورد وكل عام وانتم بخير ورمضان
كريم علينا وعلى الامه الاسلاميه حبيت
التقرير صراحه بدنا نستفيد من نصائحك
اليوم شو النصائح للحفاظ على غذاء صحي
وجسم صحي في نفس الوقت
طيب بدايه انا شفت بعض الاشي اللي اجت
بالتقرير واللي حبيت بعض الاراء منها انه
ممارسه الرياضه
ترتيب الوقت ترتيب الاكل
بدايه الاهم برمضان اني زي ما حضرتك
تفضلتوا في البدايه اني انا اعمل ارتب
اموري ل 30 يوم واحد اني انا احط خطه ايش
انا بدي اجهز لاكلي خلال 30 يوم في رمضان
بحيث اني انا اكون متاكد انه عمليه الطهي
وعمليه الطبخ تكون بطريقه صحيه
وطريقه
ما فيها دهون وما فيها بسومه اللي بيحصل
انه احنا نتغاضى عن السحور ونركز بس في
وجبه الافطار وهذه المعده اللي كانت فاضيه
16 ساعه يتم انه الواحد يهجم على الاكل
هجوم وبالتالي تجهد المعده من الاكل بعد
صيام وبالتالي التلبك وعصر هضم
والنفخه والكسل والخمول اللي بيشوفوه
الناس وبروحوا على صلاه والحلو طبعا طب
دكتور
يعني شهر رمضان
هل هو فرصه لانقاص الوزن ام لزياده الوزن
بفعل العزايم والولائم الرمضانيه
لا هذا ولا ذاك انا برايي هو هو الدوره
مجانيه بدايه تجديد كل خلايا الجسم
استغلها استغلال صحيح بمعنى انه انا شو
لازم اسوي يعني انا بما اني انا بدي احافظ
على جسمي وما اتخن بدي ادير بالي في عمليه
الاكل واتاكد اني انا عم باخد سحوري لانه
صدقيني صدقوني ان السحور هو اهم وجبه لازم
اركز عليها وبالتالي وجهه الافطار تكون
بذكاء كيف تكون بذكاء افطر بالتمر حتى
انبه الجسم والمخ انه في اكل العشرين
دقيقه من المخ الى المعده حتى تصير
التنبيه انه في اكل راح يجي على الطريق
وهون انا هذا بستغله بروح اصلي صلاه
المغرب وبرجع على الطاوله وباكل اكله
بصوره صحيحه اني انا باخذ بعد ذلك الشوربه
وبعدها السلطه حتى اخذ الالياف اللي
تحسسني بالشبع والامساك يختفي لانه معظم
المصائمين بيعانوا من الامساك في شهر
رمضان وهذا اللي عم بيجيني على العياده
دليل ان هم ما عم ياكلوا طريقه صحيحه
وبالتالي بعد التمر والصلاه والمي
والشوربه اللي انا عبيتها من الشوربه اخذت
منها الفيتامينات والمعادن باختلاف شو
نوعها والبروتين اذا عدس مثلا او دجاج
وبعد ذلك اخذت السلطه وطبق الرئيسي بروح
بصلي صلاه التراويح بصير في معاي مجال بعد
ذلك لانه صلاه التراويح لحالها رياضه وزي
ما في بعض المستمعين يتكلموا المشاهدين
قالوا انه انا بروح مشي هاي فكره جيده
بعيد المسجد مسافه هون انا عم بحرق اللي
اكلته الافطار هذا واضح طيب دكتوره في
موضوع جدلي يعاد كل رمضان
الصداع في اول ايام رمضان بسبب نقص الماء
او نقص الكافيين في هذه الحاله ماذا
تنصحين خصوصا انه فتره الافطار قبل سحور
الصباحيه فتره قصيره
[موسيقى]
توزع على السلطات والفواكه وتوزع على
الماء ليش لانه جسمك بتحس الصداع الكافيين
بياثر يسبب جفاف للجسم بيطرد المي فانا
عندي جفاف الجفاف هذا بيصير بسبب صداع
زياده الى ان والتالي انا لما برتب جسمي
بخفف وبمنع هذا الصداع اللي موجود زي ما
حكيت كل الماء واشرب الطعام طيب دكتوره
وفاء يعني هل ينبغي او هناك البعض يتجاوز
مثلا وجبه السحور ما رايك بهذا الموضوع
للاسف الشديد احدى اكبر اسباب زياده الوزن
واحد الصداع ثاني اثنين نعم نعم ليش لانه
انت عم بتصومي 16 ساعه وانت ما عم تاخذي
طاقه الجسم بيحرق السحور زي ما احنا بنقول
وجبه الفطور مهمه لانه وجبه الافطار تحرق
تماما بتعطيني الطاقه ولا تخزن على هيئه
دهون وكذلك السحور تخيلي انت قبل موعد
الافطار اذا انت كنت متصحره وهذا بعرف انه
صعب على بعض الانسان بعض الناس انهم
يقوموا يتسحروا لكن صدقوني هتلاحظوا
حياتكم بتفرق كتير لما تقوم وتتسحر شيء
بسيط فيه بروتين وكربوهيدرات لانه كتير
مهم اول اشي الكربوهيدرات ما بحسسك بالعطش
هو صديق
للعدو للعطش ليش لانه هو يحبس الماء جوه
الجسم فانت ما بتحس بالعطش اثنين الخضار
والفواكه لما انا باخذ مثلا طول مع سلطه
الطماطم خيار وكذا على السحور
الخضار والفواكه الموجوده هاي بتحسسني
بالالياف والبوتاسيوم واللي فيها كمان
بيمنع العطش اضافه لانه كل هذا بخليني
بحرقه قبل موعد افطاري بقول انا
حرقت فتره ثمان ساعات اول ثمان ساعات حرقت
كل السحور بعد ذلك يبدا حرق الدهون
المختزله داخل الجسم وبالتالي انا ما
بيزيد وزني بينما الناس اللي ما بتتسحب
اللي لا تتسحر وتعتمد على وجبه
يتم الجسم اعتمادها على اساس انها تجويع
فيخزن الدهون وبتزيد نسبه الكتله الدهنيه
في الجسم يعني
مش سحور افطار صيام رمضان المهم انه نحافظ
على لاقتنا هذا هو الاهم للاخر نظمي وقتك
تنزلي بالضبط ركبي امورك رتبي حياتك
بطريقه لذيذه الحياه سهله اذا انا رتبناها
بس انا نظمتها يعني وهذا بيمشي على كل شيء
في هالدنيا شكرا
لك دكتور